I'm thinking of buying some small fruit trees to get clean fruit in a few years.
How important is it to buy trees that are organic trees, like organic apple trees,
from the start versus conventional trees that you might get at the hardware store or something?
If we buy conventional will this synthetics be out in a few years by the time the tree
matures and we get fruit? Or if we buy conventional will the young trees struggle without the
synthetics they were started on? So, we planted, you know, we do a lot of gardening,
I think that's why this question was asked. We planted different fruit trees and you can buy
organic apple trees. I don't know about any of the other fruit trees, but I have seen the
organic apple trees. Now, in truth, is it important to buy an organic tree?
My answer to that is, I don't think so. I don't think it's important to buy an organic tree.
Now, what's the difference between an organic tree and an non-organic tree? Well,
the non-organic conventionally grown tree probably had been sprayed at some point in time,
but in truth, if you're buying a tree, that is, you know, the diameter of the tree is an
inch to an inch and a half thick, which is typically a lot of fruit trees. The chance that they sprayed
it with something is zero. They're not trying to get fruit. Therefore, you know, they're not
spraying these trees. So, I don't think there's an issue with that. Even if they did spray,
the trees for apples for the worms to keep, you know, they would be picking the fruit off of it any
how they don't want the trees to be fruity. So, I don't even think they would spend the money to
buy the spray to spray the trees. So, I do not think it's important to spend, you know, three times
the price to get an organic apple tree. If you're going to grow it organically, like our apple trees,
we never spray them, we never do anything to them. And yeah, we get some wormy apples.
We don't even, you know, there's a whole bunch of different tricks that you can do by putting
the apple cider vinegar and pops out on your tree and hang them, hang them from your tree and things
like that. We don't even do that. So, we get tons and tons of apples. We can, tons of apples, we
made, we had so many apples, we juiced so much apple juice. We had gallons and gallons of gallons
of apple juice that we put in the freezer. Freeze is really, really well. We have a dehydrator,
we dehydrated a bunch of apple slices. And we have a freeze dryer. We freeze dry tons of apples.
So much that we, you're just like, what are we going to do? We used every apple that we possibly could.
So, I think it's great to have apple trees and fruit trees. I think it's fantastic. We have giant
beds of strawberries. We have huge mungus, raspberry patch. And I make tons of jam with that. And
we freeze dry a ton of our berries. They're great for the kids, great kids to eat. So, but it's how
you grow them, what you're, what you're spraying them. Even with apple trees, they're not spraying
round up. They'd be spraying something for, the only thing that we'd spray the trees for is to keep
the worms off of the fruiting bodies so that, you know, that's not an issue, but they wouldn't be
keeping fruit on the tree anyhow. They'd be picking the fruit because it wouldn't travel well
and it wouldn't sell well. So, I don't think you have to worry about that.